I think there are two things that that
are that that stand out for me
enormously just because of how
cataclysmic the consequences are with
respect to each the first is our
contribution as human beings to the
discontinuities in in ecosystems global
warming a central among them I mean it's
I think likely that we have reached or
are about to reach various tipping
points as evidenced by what's going on
in the Arctic that are so frightening
that unless we take it more seriously
than human beings have ever taken
anything that far away and that with
that distant a time horizon we will
really limit the duration of our stay on
this planet and we will limit the
viability of the planet is a place for
other creatures to live there will be
you know after all of the ice melts and
the and the heat changes there will be
other cycles there might be other
creatures as intelligent as we are that
that climb out of the muck but I think
this is deadly serious and I think that
the real problem is that it takes
enormous leadership and international
cooperation to achieve what needs to be
achieved it takes greater self sacrifice
on the part of the most developed
nations then we are accustomed to making
especially when it's so easy to look at
a at a rising giant like China and say
that they're not going to make similar
sacrifices and maybe we can't expect
them to because they feel they have a
right to live the good life now whatever
happens in 20 generations or 30
generations but of achieving some some
synthesis in which we can be an enormous
assistance to people struggling to
achieve higher levels of welfare for
large masses of people while at the same
time controlling
and reversing the the global warming
trend i think is a an enormous challenge
one greater than any any particular
cultural trend i think a second huge
challenge is the control of weapons of
mass destruction I mean with the fall of
the Iron Curtain with the dissolution of
the USSR we entered a period of illusory
piece in which we thought we'll now you
know we could have tranquility and all
could be lovely but we really I think
paid so much less attention than we
needed to to the weapons-grade material
spread around the world and this is only
talking about uranium and plutonium and
and bombs that could be sold by the
former republics of the Soviet Union two
groups of terrorists it's not even to
look at the possibilities of biological
biological and chemical warfare but I'm
worried about about the nuclear material
and I'm worried about it I you see a
documentary and on what it was like in
the weeks and months and years after
hiroshima and nagasaki you see the
unbelievable mass suffering you imagine
what one bomb the size of the hiroshima
bomb the Nagasaki bomb in an american or
european city or a city in japan or
somewhere else could do i mean it is
beyond comprehension it's not simply
that if it happened we would quite
easily be led to throw away our
liberties and our values for some
illusory security because the fact is i
don't think that the solution to those
problems is for us suddenly become a
totalitarian police state but the fact
is that we would lose the fabric that
holds us together i mean if we had the
kind of mass disaster that that
represents given that 911 where 3,000
people died has already transformed our
culture into a culture of fear has made
it possible for probably the most
dangerous proud
in American history to be re-elected if
911 did that think what a nuclear bomb
in Boston or Detroit or San Diego would
do and it takes an enormous amount of
successful leadership to change the risk
equation of that happening to really
make it much much less likely I mean
even if the odds are only one in fifty
one in a hundred that it will happen
it's overwhelmingly unacceptable now
stepping back from those two enormous
problems I think terrorists without
weapons of mass destruction are not
nearly as horrendous a problem as they
are given the availability of those
weapons but still living in an age of
Terror where there are occasional 911s
around the world is not an acceptable
thing I mean even though people in
Northern Ireland or you know in Israel
have learned to live with a level of
suicide bombings that is quite
unthinkable to us it's really not
acceptable for the world for decades
maybe a century to live in a state of
constant fear not only because the fear
is corrosive to the human spirit but
because it corrodes Liberty it corrodes
our belief in our institutions it makes
us sell those institutions short but I
think that that is going to persist
until some very radical changes are made
in the distribution of wealth in the
world and the distribution of
information and it may be that it's
beyond our capacity to know what needs
to be done because a large part of the
world probably could be characterized as
having fanatic beliefs sort of
apocalyptic millennial beliefs beliefs
about a great afterlife that can be
produced by killing oneself and maybe
killing other people i think the suicide
bomber is an exceptional phenomenon at
the moment but in most of the world the
separation between theocracy and
politics that we have experienced
is not present in most of the world
there is a belief that there is a divine
plan that makes one's political vision
the right vision and people imbued with
that belief are not given to great
tolerance and not given to exchange and
cooperation and if people have that
belief and a number of them are
desperate and see little for themselves
and in this life the number of people
are going to want to go and blow up
trains blow up buildings is is great and
we are spawning more and more of those
people by what we are now doing in Iraq
we're certainly spawning them by what we
are threatening to do in Iran it seems
to me that helping to generate a world
where terror and terrorists thrive and
and become more dominant even apart from
their access to weapons of mass
destruction it should be seen as so
terrible mistake that that should be a
large part of the calculus of what we
are wasting in terms of human life and
resources in Iraq it's not just that
we're going to be spending two trillion
dollars on these wars that are so
unfocused it's that we're going to be
generating hundreds of thousands of
terrorists some of whom will get their
hands on nuclear weapons and we're
dooming our own future so the need to
make sort of radical advances in
diplomacy the need to get deeper into
the sources of the despair that lead to
terror the sources of the mindset that
lead to sort of fanatic Jihad's around
the world that's an urgent need as well